Salve youtubers e benvenuti in una nuova
puntata di della web radio che dai
commenti dell'ultima volta mi sembra che
abbiate cambiato idea Vabbè fate
voi oggi si parlerà di cucina
incredibilmente argomento che tocco
veramente di rado e infatti qui con noi
in linea c'è Livia una ragazza di 17
anni che ha un canale molto carino Ciao
Livia Ciao a tutti parlaci un attimo del
tuo canale invece invece di
Allora ho deciso di aprire questo canale
Perché diciamo non volevo entrare nel
mondo di YouTube però non sapevo cosa
fare perché diciamo di trucco me ne
intendo davvero poco altre cose tipo non
so giochi cose comiche anche zero
diciamo l'unica cosa in cui me la cavavo
un po' meglio era appunto la cucina e ne
avevo visti pochi di canali su questo
argomento soprattutto fatti da persone
normali perché quelli che ci sono la
maggior parte parte sono su cuochi o
programmi famosi e quindi niente Ho
deciso di aprire questo canale e vedere
far vedere un po' la gente come si fanno
dolci e cose varie Ok quindi sì un un
bellissimo canale di tutorial Tra
l'altro spiegati molto molto bene
Già ti ho notata grazie a guasta 11 che
ti aveva Sì mi aveva nominata Sì sì Ehm
Quindi tu fai tutorial perché ho visto
la maggior parte sono di dolci li farai
solo di dolci o anche di eh eh no Guarda
la mia passione soprattutto sono i dolci
anche mangiarli naturalmente Però
diciamo che eh nel futuro vorrei fare
anche non so pasta o altri primi secondi
che vado un po' a periodi In questo
periodo sono più dolci poi magari dopo
Natale mi riprendo ho capito E allora
parliamo proprio di questa passione
Perché in fondo è proprio questo
qualsiasi cosa si fa nella vita con
piacere credo sia una una passione parlo
da cioè da da uno che fa più o meno le
stesse tue cose quindi è una cosa che
hai sempre avuto la passione su del
della cucina Eh sì perché diciamo Mia
nonna è non è una cuoca però non so se
avete presente quelle nonne che stanno
sempre a fare la sfoglia così e quindi
io da piccola l' aiutavo mi piaceva
impastare fare dolci creare cose quindi
diciamo mi è sempre piaciuto cucinare
provare nuove nuove ricette così poi non
ho mai fatto niente di di professionale
corsi o robe varie ho imparato dai libri
appunto da mia nonna da mia madre cose
proprio a casa Niente di speciale Ah ho
capito Quindi così E hai anche risposto
alla domanda dopo c'è c'è qualcuno che
ti aiuta a fare queste cose o Cioè o hai
imparato ormai a fare tutto da te No
vabbè però mia nonna non sta qui a Roma
perché io sono di Roma però soprattutto
mia madre quando non so ho qualche
dubbio o cose così mi aiuta però di
solito soprattutto adesso con questa
storia di YouTube cerco ricette su
internet su libri che compro in libreria
e e se ce la faccio faccio tutto da sola
Poi se magari mi viene qualche dubbio
appunto chiedo consiglio a chi è più
esperto di me ovviamente ovviamente
quindi Beh ovviamente ci vuole una buona
dose di fantasia per fare le cose oltre
che la tecnica eh Sì beh certo fantasia
ci vuole un po' Comunque quindi se se
c'è aiuta soprattutto magari per
decorare o per aggiungere qualche tocco
in più rispetto alla ricetta base
diciamo
ovviamente Adesso vorrei dire delle cose
che dico raramente perché la gente di
solito non capisce però parlando con
qualcuno che
magari in campo artistico diciamo perché
in fondo cucinare più o meno un'arte
come tutte e allora cioè ho ho capito
studiando anche il campo campo artistico
che ehm Se vuoi fare una cosa
teoricamente non si può imparare
soprattutto ripeto in campo artistico
cioè lo devi avere dentro disegnare per
esempio c'è il mio amico che fa il
disegnatore e se non ce l'hai dentro È
impossibile imparare a disegnare Secondo
te è la stessa cosa anche per la cucina
Beh allora Secondo me per imparare Si
può imparare se uno appunto ha la
passione e magari uno non sa niente però
ha sempre avuto Non lo so ha sempre
stato affascinato dalla da cucinare e
cose così secondo me può imparare però
se magari uno è svogliato preferisce
andare a prendersi il panino da
McDonald's così che imparare a fare Non
lo so una pasta al pomodoro Eh lì è
difficile L'importante appunto averci la
voglia e poi se nasce In secondo luogo
la passione è molto importante secondo
me mh eh beh Anche secondo me
soprattutto la voglia quindi ci vuole
una pazienza im mane per fare queste
cose così tanta eh Dipende dalle cose
cioè ci sono delle ricette che sono
immediate velocissime Poi appunto ci
sono certe cose che bisogna stare lì
sudare soprattutto impegnarsi Perché
certe volte magari uno fa una cosa
sbaglia un passaggio e deve rifare tutto
da capo e lì Diciamo Ti saltano un po' i
nervi però se non c'è soprattutto stare
attenti E concentrati quando si fanno
ste cose anche perché alla fine poi te
le mangi tu e se non è buono è difficile
poi ti dai la zappa sui piedi poi ti
uccidi da solo ehm Hai mai pensato di
usare cioè questa passione per te è è
talmente forte che in futuro potresti
usarla proprio come lavoro potresti
farla diventare un lavoro eh Ci l'altro
giorno ci stavo appunto pensando però
non so perché cioè mi piace farlo per me
per i miei amici i miei familiari però
il come lavoro non so perché
non mi Fedo abbastanza non ispirata con
quel tocco in più che ne so che sai
creare qualcosa di nuovo mettere qualche
ingrediente strano non so magari in un
futuro adesso dico così ma in un futuro
ci sarà qualche occasione però ora come
ora non mi vedo in quel campo da grande
Ah ma quindi Tu segui diciamo delle
ricette già Cè già fatte Sì magari
cambio qualche ingrediente metto
qualcosa di mio però in generale non non
è che mi invento le cose dal nulla
prendo ricette o dai libri o ricette
proprio di famiglia così ho capito Eh E
visto che fai questi tutorial Perché non
dai qualche consiglio a chi si volesse
avvicinare visto che hai detto che
chiunque può imparare in modo che non
faccia esplodere la cucina appena Tocca
qualcosa Vabbè Innanzitutto non lasciare
il gas aperto perché esemp credo che
quello sia una cosa fondamentale poi Beh
allora iniziare Soprattutto dalle basi
perché
ehm naturalmente uno non è che può
arrivare e credere di poter fare la
torta da matrimonio a 50 Pian o c così
Bisogna sempre piano piano iniziare da
dalle cose più facili e la cosa
importante che mi ribate sempre sia mio
padre sia mia nonna è scegliere gli
ingredienti giusti ingredienti non da
diciamo non da supermercato voglio dire
più la qualità è migliore più oltre alla
tecnica che che hai più il risultato
sarà buono perché se uno usa le uova
fresche invece delle uova che sono state
in frigo una settimana è tutta un'altra
cosa è che la gente non lo sa dice uova
prende le uova qualsiasi immag Eh vabbè
poi quando quando si può è meglio così
se non si può ci si accontenta lo stesso
ma secondo te perché soprattutto le
ragazze sono portate per la cucina
mentre i ragazzi non dico di no perché
cuochi maschi ce ne sono parecchi però
molto meno
eh Ecco questa è una bella domanda anche
perché volevo fare un esempio tipo mio
padre no lui non l' ammetterebbe mai
perché non non si sente così ma per me è
un grande non dico cuoco però cucina
molto bene a parte il fatto che
purtroppo a lui non piacciono i dolci
Quindi
praticamente sono io l'unica mangiatrice
qui a casa Vabbè poi rifornisco tutta la
scuola Pra da quando ho aperto il canale
sì E secondo me sono soprattutto le le
femmine Perché i maschi della mia età
diciamo lo vedono un po' troppo
come un lavoro da da donne da femmine
come se si gli sminuisce magari siamo
fermi nel nel Medioevo Eh non lo so
perché se no perché comunque come grandi
cuochi maschi ce ne sono Però appunto
che che non hanno 15 1520 anni No
ovviamente no poi naturalmente ci sarà
qualche ragazzo appassionato però non so
perché soprattutto le donne forse perché
è così non so storicamente se si può
dire non so perché precisamente Beh
comunque cioè parlando da parte degli
uomini Credo che sia proprio per il
motivo che hai detto che avvicinarsi
magari a fornelli può cioè no può
rendere può sembrare un lavoro da donne
proprio c'è questa mentalità un po'
Antica eh Un po' scusa Però vabbè
comunque anche un aspetto non da
sottovalutare è il fatto che una cosa
che hai fatto tu oltre ad essere più
buona perché non è confezionata
conservanti e robe varie anche il fatto
che l'hai fatto tu con le tue mani lo fa
Sembra molto ma davvero molto più buono
perché tutto il lavoro che ci ha messo
la passione e la fatica migliorano molto
come sapore Eh immagino immagino ma
comunque sì Cioè in generale qualsiasi
cosa ti prepari da solo è molto più
buona Almeno per esperienza personale
Cioè non è che mi faccia chissà cosa
però già solo un panino comprato al bar
un panino che mi faccio io son tutto
diverso Esatto par parliamo di panini
con te che fai dolci allucinanti
Comunque no vabbè ma anch'io mi faccio i
panini Non immaginate che a pranzo mi
faccio Chissà l'arrosto robe varie
Eh va bene Allora io ti ringrazio
ehm Seguirò continuerò a seguire il
canale ovviamente grazie mille grazie a
te per questa possibilità soprattut Ah
figurati Tanto lo faccio apposta per voi
io e e quindi ti ringrazio io vi invito
a ad iscrivervi al suo Canale poi Linker
il tuo canale nelle informazioni e ci
sentiamo alla prossima web radio Ciao Ok
grazie Ciao